Nói 7 đường cho rằng sản xam đi đám cưới bị khuế tổ.
Chương ngày 18, 2, các quan cạnh rất đều tra công an tình thêm quá, khuế tổ năm bị cà đều là nhân viên công ty chế giểm hiểu hạn về sĩ sự kiểu rí ti,
quốc, lê kiên thức, khoảng văn chung, mưỡin định dương, lâm văn thủy và lê hả đông về tổy với giối trực tự công cộp,
theo đều bà trà mẹ tám bộ lợi thình dự.
Nhà chức chắc cao buộc hành vi tự ý, giạp đường của nhóm về sĩ triệu ngày 20, tự thống mùi một la không đúng trước năng những vụ,
người anh gần số đến tình dình anh nhìn chật tự.
Cuối thống về một trên mạng xa hội lan chuyên một số video gí cạnh nhiều vệ sĩ công gẩn đu khiến rất thông trên đại lộ lê lợi,
thinh quá, khi đàn xe đám cưới đi qua.
Đàn xe không trước hành tình dự nhiều đen đó, khiến rất tổ vốn là.
Chức thông tin nhóm vệ sĩ trong lúc dẹp đường đã trận xe của tự lệ quân của bốn,
con ăn tình thình quá cho 2 lự dung này khu chính xác.